good morning reg good morning theodore
de joy my dad did you watch the game
listen I did what a great college game I
think a few weeks ago we were talking
about you know the college football
landscape and why are they having all
the bolt all these bowl games in I said
look it's to me if the two bowls that
really matter you know the final four
and i know the michigan game was a great
bowl game don't get me wrong but this
was arguably one of the greatest bowl
games especially for a national
championship personally I've ever seen
because you're right and great boxing
analogy because to me I thought Alabama
kind of went to you know prevent when
they were up 14 nothing they had a
chance to go up 21 24 nothing and really
put this game away and I thought they
played conservative in the first half
and Cleveland just hung around and
stayed close stayed within striking
distance waiting for their opportunity
for that overhand right and we saw a lot
of those overhand rights in that second
half I know that leading into this game
I said that it's better for college
football Clemson wins then Alabama wins
again although I thought one of the
story lines would be Nick Saban's place
in history he still has a pretty secure
spot in history but the point that I
bring up reg is Bill Simmons on his
podcast said that savings had coward
because he doesn't coach in the NFL you
don't coach with the best and my point
is if that's the case then there have
been a lot of cowards in college sports
okay so is Coach K an hour then yes yeah
that's ridiculous that's ridiculous to
say because he has coached in the NFL
Miami was a very successful in major
Billy's joke maybe's jokey maybe it's
timmy was joking but I mean to call
someone a coward I mean yeah you
probably was joking about it but in my
opinion Nick Saban is the greatest
college coach ever and I know that you
know people are saying well what about
Bear Bryant to me in today's age of
recruiting and more teams I think he is
the greatest college coach collegiate
coach ever to play the game no matter if
the war on last night or not
um just for the simple fact of what he
has done with that Alabama program year
in year out they are always battling for
the national championship and again they
have another great recruiting class
coming in and they just turn it over and
to be in the national championship game
with a true freshman quarterback that
was pretty amazing and to do that all
throughout the SEC is uh something so
yeah my opinion he's the greatest but
does it take anything away from Coach K
that he hasn't coached in the NBA
flirted with the lake absolutely not you
know uh is is uh John Wooden a coward
because he never know coached in uh are
coached in the NBA know that there's
some guys that are tailor-made for the
pros tailor-made for college tailor-made
for high school that was your calling
this is Coach K's John Wooden Nixon
maybe this is their calling why does it
have to be at the highest professional
level for everyone to say oh ok well now
he's the greatest no I mean would feel
Jackson would red auerbach be a
successful in the college game I mean
who knows that was their calling so you
know I love Bill Simmons but the Causton
want to coward because he's not doing it
at the highest level kind of ridiculous
to me he's the Hall of Famer Reggie
Miller joining is speaking to Phil
Jackson the Knicks lost their point
guard Derrick Rose they couldn't find
him or he lost the Knicks last night I I
know if even if it's a family emergency
Reggie I just can't imagine somebody not
being at least attentive enough to send
spend 30 seconds to say I won't be there
for the game last night what what's your
big question here with Derrick Rose
going m.i.a well once again it's the
leveling of my beloved Knicks anyways
you I'm gonna give you proper protocol
on on family emergencies when things
happen normally as a player this is what
I would have done and this is what most
players would do I would have called
Donnie Walsh the general manager of
President of the Pacers and told him
whatever the family emergency was
probably when I hung up the phone the
next phone call would have been to David
Craig the head trainer because he has a
direct line right into the coach / call
David told him what the emergency was
and that would have been it I am NOT
going to you know get on Derrick Rose um
because we don't you and I don't know
what the family of urgency was so we're
all human even though we're athletes
were human and things happen what I do
have a problem with is not calling
someone and letting them know that and
for the simple fact that for the whole
game even afterwards the Knicks had no
idea where he was and it's not fair to
coach Jeff hornacek to get in front of
the firing squad called the New York
media and for them to pepper him with
all these questions and he has zero
answers to me those questions and those
answers need to be coming from Phil
Jackson yep not the head coach that's
what I have a problem with Phil need to
get in front of the firing squad he was
at the game he knew Derrick Rose wasn't
there why wasn't he doing his own
reconnaissance and getting getting ahead
of the story getting in front of the
media and saying or or himself having
their own NBA security try to locate
Derrick Rose I want to hear from Phil
Jackson not Jeff hornacek god bless them
but that this is not the head coach's
job to be a babysitter Phil Jackson's
the one who brought Derrick Rose in I
want to hear from Hill yeah I did too I
didn't think it was fair to hornacek to
coach a game and then all of a sudden go
in and you know how much does he know
when did they know Rose was not going to
be playing in the game and even if it's
a family emergency somebody should have
known something because the Knicks look
like they're not all in the same page it
was pretty embarrassing and Theodore
this is not a story if the Knicks have
not lost 8 of 9 this is not a story if
the Knicks at home vs new orleans
pelicans and yes they've played better
as of late but a 15 win team comes into
the garden and absolutely destroys you
with Anthony Davis going for 40 and 18
so you put all that in the gumbo
hot you mix it on up and then the m.i.a
of Derrick Rose a former MVP and I got
that was supposed to be the savior at
point guard for you who was brought in
from the Hall of Famer Phil Jackson and
that's why it's a big story because
everyone's like was he kidnapped to some
man there's something happening to
Derrick Rose I mean this is one of the
most visible athletes on the planet in
Derrick Rose and you're playing for
you're playing him in number one media
market in New York so that's why it's
such a big stories because no one knew
or derrick rose was and that's the only
problem I have with Derrick Rose if you
have a family emergency I get it we are
all human and you've gotta handle your
business go go to Chicago and take care
of that but pick up the phone and call
Phil Jackson and then you call your head
trainer and then that's it you don't
even have to call the coach it's not a
stereo gonna go reg it's not a story if
he does that your story if you make the
phone call no one's going to say no
one's going to say anything about a
family emergency because we are all
human beings but when you don't call
that's why it makes it look like it's
more than a family emergency yes she's
been benched the last two games in the
fourth for Ron Baker the rookie out of
Wichita State Brandon Jennings has been
benched the point guard play has been
terrible and he was at the shooter round
at eleven o'clock going over things and
to me if you're a head coach in your
other players you know what's going on
in that locker room you know if Derrick
Rose's upset about the binging and if
you think that he's going through the
motions already sulking you can kind of
tell something's on the horizon to me
that's why I think it's more than a
family emergency but again people I'm
just saying this dan Theodore my den
nets and myself we don't know we don't
know what the family emergency was we're
only going by what everyone is
speculating so that's why I can't get on
for that but pick up the damn phone and
call Phil Jackson and call the trainer
and it would be no story Cavs traded for
Kyle Korver what's this mean and do you
see the Cavs is this it do they make any
more moves uh I don't and I think what
initially when this first happened I
thought well JR smith is probably gonna
be out a little bit
than what we expected some people
thought he was going to come back right
after the all-star break some said maybe
going into the first round of the
playoffs it's an insurance policy and if
I'm Kyle Korver I'm looking to the
heavens and I'm saying thank you Jesus
because this is one of if not the best
catch and shoot three-point players
maybe in history and to be perched in
that short three-point corner or at the
trailing on fast breaks and to have
LeBron James and Kyrie Irving who are
fantastic and collapsing the defense
just said should I want you to put on
your little baby bibs and just sit in
that corner and look pretty you know
dirty desi don't put the baby in the
corner Kyle Korver go stay in that
corner and just relax in Sheol it will
get you and that's what he has to do so
I'm to me great pick up fabulous pick up
Reggie aloysius Miller will try to sell
Detroit against Golden State Thursday if
Golden State it's Reggie Jackson it's
stan van gundy Andre Drummond that's a
good sale yeah no yeah 1030 eastern on
tnt reg safe travels we'll talk to you
soon thank you Theodore you are
absolutely the best and if I could do
one thing for one year and take off of
TNT yeah I would be a pro mountain biker
cross country / inderal I wish I could
take a year off and just travel around
and do all the top courses and be a pro
mountain biker no it was a dream come
true yet that would be my one year away
from turner well you do get six months
off from Turner can't you just do it
then I need the other significant you'll
need the other six months to recover
yeah I do Thank You reg you're the best
guy that's a Reggie Aloysius Miller I
wouldn't expect that with reg don't know
mountain biking the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]